[Applause]
hello I'm sure by the time I get to the
end of this sentence given how I talk
you'll all have figured out that I'm
from a place called planet Earth Earth
is pretty great
it's home to us and germs those take a
backseat for the time being cuz bleed or
not they're not the only thing going on
this planet is also home to cars
Brussels sprouts those weird fish things
that have their own headlights art fire
fire extinguishers laws pigeons bottles
of beer lemons and light bulbs Pinot
Noir and paracetamol ghosts mosquitoes
flamingos flowers the ukulele elevators
and cats cat videos the internet iron
beams buildings and batteries all
ingenuity and bright ideas all known
life and a whole bunch of other stuff
pretty much everything we know and ever
heard of it's my favorite place actually
this small orb floating in a cold and
lonely part of the cosmos oh the accent
is from Belfast by the way which is here
roughly you may think you know this
planet Earth you're from here but
chances are you probably haven't thought
about the basics you know what I thought
I knew it thought I was an expert even
until that is I had to explain the
entire place and how it's supposed to
work
to someone who'd never been here before
not what you might think hello my dad
always did say the surest sign of
intelligent life right there is that
they haven't bothered trying to contact
us it was actually my newborn son I was
trying to explain things to you we'd
never been parents before my wife and I
on so treated him like most guests when
he arrived home for the first time by
giving him the tour this is where you
live son this trim is where we make food
art this is the room we keep our
collection of chairs and so on it's
refreshing explaining how our planet
works to a zero year old but after the
laughs once the magnitude that you
humans know absolutely nothing
settles on you and little you know
either explaining the whole planet
becomes quite intimidating but I tried
anyway as I walked around those
a few weeks narrating the world as I saw
it I began to take notes of the
ridiculous things I was saying the notes
slowly morphed into a letter intended
for my son once he learned to read and
that letter became a book about the
basic principles of what it is to be a
human living on earth in the 21st
century some things are really obvious
like the planet is made of two parts
land and sea
some less obvious and till you think
about them like time things can
sometimes move slowly here on earth but
more often they move quickly so use your
time well it'll be gone before you know
it or people people come in all
different shapes sizes and colors we may
all look different act different and
sign different but don't be fooled we
are all people it doesn't escape me that
of all the places in the universe people
only live on earth can only live on
earth and even then only on some of the
dry bits there's only a very small part
of the surface of our planet that is
actually habitable to human life and
squeezed in here is where all of us live
it's easy to forget when you're up close
to the dirt the rocks the foliage the
concrete of our lands just high limited
the room for maneuvering is from a set
of eyes close to the ground the horizon
phase like it goes forever after all
it's not an everyday ritual to consider
where we are on the ball of our planet
and where that ball is in space I didn't
want to tell my son the same story of
countries that we were told where I was
growing up at Northern Ireland that we
were from just a small parish which
ignores a life outside its immediate
concerns I wanted to try to feel what it
was like to see our planet as one system
as a single object hanging in space to
do this I would need to switch from flat
drawings or books so the 3d sculpture
for the street and I'd need almost 200
feet a new york city block to build a
large-scale model of the moon the earth
and us this project managed to take
place on New York City's Highline Park
last winter on the 50th anniversary of
Apollo 11s mission around the moon after
its installation I was able to put on a
space helmet with my son and launch like
Apollo 11 did a half-century ago to
we circled around and look back at us
what I felt was how lonely it was there
in the dark and I was just pretending
the moon is the only object even
remotely close to us and at the scale of
this project where our planet was ten
feet in diameter Mars the next planet
will be the size of a yoga ball and a
couple of miles away below borders are
not visible from space on my sculpture
every single border was drawn in but
rather than writing the country names in
the carved up land I wrote over and over
again people live here people live here
people live here and often the muna was
written no one lives here often the
obvious things aren't all that obvious
until you think about them seeing
anything from a vast enough distance
changes everything as many astronauts
have experienced and human eyes have
only ever seen our earth from as far as
the moon really it's quite a ways
further before we get to the edges of
our own solar system even to other stars
to the constellations there is actually
only one point in the entire cosmos that
is present in all constellations of
stars and that presence is here planet
Earth
those pictures we have made up for the
clusters of stars only makes sense from
this point of view deine hear their
stories only makes sense here on earth
and only something to us to people we
are creatures of stories we are the
stories we tale we're the stories we're
told consider briefly the story of human
civilization on earth it tells of the
ingenuity elegance generous and
nurturing nature of species that is also
self focused vulnerable and defiantly
protective we the people shield the
flame of our existence from the raw and
vast elements outside our control the
grid beyond yet it is always to the
flame we look for all we know when said
is a statement it means the sum total of
all knowledge but one said another way
for all we know it means that we do not
know at all
this is the beautiful fragile drama of
civilization we are the actors and
spectators of a cosmic play that means
the word us here but means nothing
anywhere else possibly not even that
much done here either if we truly
thought about our relationship with our
boat with our earth it might be more of
a story of ignorance and greed as is the
case with Fausto a man who believed he
owned everything and set out to survey
what was his he easily claims ownership
of a floor a sheep a tree and a failed
the lake in the mountain proved harder
to conquer but they to surrender but
isn't trying to own the open sea where
his greed proves his undoing when in a
fit of arrogance he climbs overboard to
shoe that see who is boss but he does
not understand slips beneath the waves
and sinks to the bottom the sea was sad
for him but carried on being the sea as
do all the other objects of his
ownership but the fear of fossil does
not matter to them but all the
importance in the cosmos we believe we
hold we'd have nothing if not for this
earth what it would keep happily
spinning obliviously without us on this
planet there are people we have gone
about our days sometimes we look up a
night mostly we will have died and then
looking up and by drawing lines between
the lights in the sky we've attempted to
make sense out of chaos looking down we
drawn lines across the land to know
where we belong and where we don't we do
mostly forget that these lines that
connect the Stars and those lines that
divide the land live only in our heads
they too are stories we carry out our
everyday routines and rituals according
to the stories we most believe in at
these days the story is changing as we
write it there's a lot of fear in this
current story and until recently the
stories that seemed to have the most
part are those of bitterness of hard it
all going wrong for us individually and
collectively it has been inspiring to
watch our the best comes from the worst
our people are waking up in this time of
global reckoning to the realization that
our connections with each other are some
of the most important things we have
but stepping back bro all we've had to
lament spend very little time relishing
the single biggest thing that has ever
gone right for us that we are here in
the first place that we are alive at all
that we are still alive a million and a
half years after finding a box of
matches we haven't totally burned the
high Stein yet the chances of being here
are infinitesimal
yet here we are perils at all there have
never been more people living on earth
using more stuff and it's become obvious
that many of the old systems we invented
for ourselves are obsolete and we have
to build new ones if it wasn't germs our
collective fire may suffocate us before
as we watch the wheels of Industry grind
to a halt
the machinery of progress becomes silent
we have the wildest of opportunities
take the reset button to take a
different path here we are on earth and
life on Earth is a wonderful thing it
looks big this earth but there are lots
of us on here seven and a half billion
at last count with more showing up every
day even so there is still enough for
everyone if we all share it so please be
kind
when you think of it another way if
Earth is the only place where people
live it's actually the least lonely
place in the universe there are plenty
of people to be loved by and plenty of
people to love we need each other we
know that now more than ever goodnight
[Music]